bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france à l'heure des
manifestations géantes contre jaillir
ball son art ou une enquête en cours est
ce qu'on peut dire que les temps soient
auxerre au tour du président rentrée
julien bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bien non au fait le brésil est habitué à
la crise économique sociale politique
permanente depuis l'élection de gossau
naroff est à vendre déjà une ligne puis
schümann de dilma rousseff en 2016 si ma
mémoire est bonne donc non rossonero est
toujours soutenue comme vous l'avez dit
par une grande partie du congrès et pas
une trentaine de pour cent de l'opinion
publique aux fins de selon les sondages
qui est à fond propres sonar ont donc
vous avez un pays qui est très très
divisés très polarisée et finalement
je pense qu'il faut attendre les
élections devant prochain 2010 il n y
aura beaucoup de bruit mais je vois mal
le président être être destitué tomber
son analyse mais dans ces manifestations
géantes en cd ou pour demander le départ
du président car il n'aurait pas bien
j'avais la crise sanitaire mais plus
généralement pour dénoncer toute sa
politique
est ce que finalement le kobe de la
crise sanitaire n'a pas été le
détonateur de la défiance des brésiliens
face au président ya disons que une vain
la gauche brésilienne comme beaucoup de
ses consoeurs dans le monde n'a pas
compris qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
s'appelle alternance dans une démocratie
donc quand de suivre son arbre a été
élue la bouche a refusé tout simplement
qu'il gère le p
donc nous avons eu toutes les crises où
les scandales amazonie maintenant le
coronary retourner contre lui on a
l'impression que le brésil a inventé le
virus et qui la propagent et donc le
brésil est une victime de ce virus
le système de santé brésilienne est pas
si mauvais que ça il a mais il avait des
problèmes depuis toujours donc la bouche
à l'entrée
il découvre les problèmes du système de
santé de résidents la corruption alors
que la gauche a gouverné le pays de 2000
à 2015 elle aurait pu réformer les
hôpitaux y lutter contre la corruption
je rappelle que lula a été condamné en
plusieurs instances pour corruption
donc tout ça c'est vraiment la politique
démagogique
les brésiliens sont en train de mourir
non seulement du corona mais de faim
enfin j'exagère un peu c'est pas la fin
c'est la malnutrition moi je vis à 100
par l'eau les rues n'ont jamais été
aussi plein de mendiants on voit des
gens qui viennent d'être déclassé d'être
clochardisé ça fait très mal au coeur
alors est ce que c'est la faute du
confinement comme le libre son art au la
faute du virus l'histoire jugera pour
l'instant il ya une grande détresse
sociale dans ce pays et je n'ai pas vu
ces manifestants la apporter de l'aide
aux mendiants ils sont en train de faire
une croix à contrôler son art ou
pourquoi pas mais je veux dire le
problème des gens qui m'entourent
aujourd'hui dans le brésil
ce n'est pas celui-là c'est l'inflation
l'accrocheur lisation les enfants qui ne
vont pas à l'école depuis deux ans
c'est ça vraiment j'ai l'impression
qu'ils soient les les plaines de notre
quotidien et je vois ces manifestations
sont complètement dans un monde qui
n'existe pas mais ce sont des
préoccupations qui sont lointaines si je
comprends bien vous êtes en train de
dire que finalement les manifestants et
l'opposition c'est tromper d'ennemi
disons que l'opposition ne se connecte
toujours pas au peuple
pourquoi parce qu'elle a pas de leader
d'où le le retour de lula qui a été
orchestrée je vous rappelle que pendant
la pandémie
pendant que
on faisait le mélodrame sur les vaccins
pendant que les brésiliens mouret l'acte
suprême à la veine où ils ont lavé lula
de toutes ces condamnations donc il est
vierge pour revenir aux élèves pour être
éligible l'an prochain c'est ça le vrai
jeu politique et donc c'est cette
élection cette proposition là et elle a
besoin de nous là pour se reconnecter au
peuple parce que même en faisant tout le
mélodrame d'assured le grenat le peuple
n'est pas là moi je vois pas de deux
brésiliens de toutes les couleurs je
vois pas de brésiliens des classes
populaires je vois des professeurs des
syndicalistes des gens de la bourgeoisie
qui ont eu le loisir de se confiner chez
eux parce qu'ils étaient payés le vrai
que je le vois pas ici presque gagné
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions répète que vous étiez en
direct de sao paulo et que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales
martial